the topic today says business plan it's
more about raising venture money and
arguably from a perspective that
everybody you heard from the prior
session may not agree with it's a very
Sequoia specific look at what we look
for we're thinking about making an
investment in a series a company my own
background I was actually in this room
and the date myself here close to 18
years ago Ken Osmond and Robert Maxfield
from Rome Fame we're teaching the very
early years of this entrepreneurship
program I didn't start a company that
year but about 6 or 7 years later it was
part of the inspiration for me to take a
risk and start a company which I had the
good fortune of having Sequoia back
about seven years ago I've gone to the
dark side and that's how I view it but
I'm happy to share with you a
perspective of both an entrepreneur and
an investor and I will be as transparent
as possible today so I encourage you to
ask questions this is a workshop it
won't be about detailed business
planning it will give you some insight
into what I perceive to be the mystery
in dealing with venture capitalists you
know all these odd behavior patterns and
I just encourage you to ask today
throughout the conversation so the title
I have yours think big start small so
take a look at those pictures Jerry and
David Larry and Sergey Steve Chad and
for those of you that actually into
YouTube lore Jawad so look at that set
of faces this is the formative time and
each one of these companies and today
think about what they actually represent
so Yahoo at this point in time was
really a web directory for Stanford not
much more many people would argue today
that's a feature Google or wasn't a
search engine it was all about PageRank
and improving search for the search
enza's kind of a middleware offer in
many ways YouTube was about sharing
video from parties with one another
the point I'm trying to make is you
think about these three companies you
could have made all sorts of arguments
about market size not being large enough
feature rather than the product but in
all cases is a great deal of passion and
energy around a specific pain point they
started very small not a lot of fancy
titles no 42 Long's no fabulous resume
of experience and that's all in the last
decade if you go back another 10-15
years there are the Steve's from Apple a
company today that associated with so
many wonderful consumer businesses they
are going after the hobby computer
market at the point of time that Don
Valentine invested very small market
Tripp was a middle manager at Apple who
was the pioneer behind Electronic Arts a
publishing company I think most he were
familiar with at the time was really a
single game single product hoping to run
on Commodore 64 and a couple other open
computers boy talk about a market size
problem and then sandy and land they
were here at Stanford in the IT
department worried about connecting Dec
VAX decnet environments and SNA to not
IP networks but NSFNET the point I'm
trying to make with this is that we
regularly see entrepreneurs come in and
talk about billion-dollar market its
large Tam's
and that's just not as interesting to us
as the passion that comes from trying to
solve a very specific pain point for a
very specific customer focus focus focus
so this is a framework that you'll see
in mark Leslie's sales learning curve
work in fact I'm just curious how many
of you have actually read the case sales
learning curve from mark Leslie okay if
you haven't you should please put it on
your list it's a fabulous case about
startups in the early days a-week what
we call revenue ramp and I'll talk
further about it but it's something that
very few entrepreneurs that walk in
actually get this framework lays out the
three P's and marketing key qualities
that we look for in products and the
whole go to market strategy in many
cases this might be a hundred pages or
longer to really knock out a decent
business plan we're not interested in
that I have to tell you on a regular
basis I'll get a hundred hundred and
twenty page well-thought-out
well-written business plan from
entrepreneurs across the globe it's such
an iterative process it changes almost
every month it's just not interesting to
us so when you think about how to spend
that first hour with the venture
community and I always wondered about
this myself as an entrepreneur what do I
want to spend my time on at least it
Sequoia there are handful questions we
ask ourselves and we're hoping to get
answers to in that first hour what's
compelling and unique and the words
compelling and unique you really need to
dwell and focus on and I'll talk further
about that
what is your unfair advantage this is
really about market strategy and market
tactics if you convince us that one and
two are interesting we want to hear all
about the great technology but not
necessarily from a end-user perspective
we're interested in it as a shareholder
I'll talk about what that means defining
team and here we're probably contrarian
we're less interested in your executive
BIOS and a lot of the titles that might
be important to some of you and more
interested in the DNA of the actual
founding team and then finally finance
and financials a lot of people make
mistakes that we don't pay attention to
financials oh no we do I have a couple
partners that well literally in a
presentation if you hand them the deck
flip to the financials and we'll shred
them within 90 seconds
I'll talk about the things that they're
looking for compelling a unique this is
probably the most difficult challenge
for entrepreneurs to tackle I remember
spending almost 90 days on this myself
with my co-founder Monte Kirsten at
vital signs trying to determine what our
unique compelling value proposition was
and how we would position ourselves in
the marketplace incredibly challenging
I've got here a very compelling value
proposition from Cisco they network
networks pretty simple not even a couple
sentences down to a couple of words but
the point is that we're looking for
clarity of purpose and that's not only
important to us as investors will be
important to the marketplace at large to
your potential partners to potential
recruits and it's something that
candidly very few entrepreneurs get when
they walk in the door in two three
declarative senses can you explain to us
what's unique compelling why you're
different and how you're ultimately
going to win and what you're unfair
advantages so there is a template which
I'm hoping many of you are familiar with
from Jeffrey Moore how many people have
read inside the tornado of crossing the
chasm still the Bible in high-tech
marketing jeff has a positioning
template which it looks like it's easy
to fill out but if it's really going to
be tight compelling and unique it's very
challenging I point out that the initial
challenge is picking your target
customer we hear often about target
customers being the Fortune 2000 or 18
to 35 year olds almost at that point I'm
not interesting to us who knows who the
face book was for the target customer
was for face book
very students college toons Harvard
students thank you
what is it today anybody familiar with a
couple of interesting examples insider
pages which was a local search site one
we backed and their focus their initial
target market was all of North America
arguably a white pages there was another
little startup to some of you who might
hang out in San Francisco could be
familiar with as well
started by one of the alums from PayPal
I won't mention the company's name but
they decided that their target market
was clubbers in San Francisco one of the
two companies is still a defendant today
the point is this template in really
focusing on the key elements that Moore
lays out in both of his books inside of
the tornado and crossing the chasm
incredibly important and if you can get
through this phase boy are we interested
probably one in 15 entrepreneurs that
comes through our doors in literally
five minutes can convey their initial
market position
so here's an example from Silicon
Graphics a company that is faded which
certainly had fabulous glory if that
Google is located in their campus today
if you're familiar with the Google
campus for movie producers who have
post-production special effects Silicon
Graphics provides computer workstations
that integrate digital fantasies and
with film footage unlike IBM or Sun
Microsystems their prime competitors SGI
is made a no compromise commitment to
meeting filmmakers post-production needs
might be worried about market size we
wouldn't a lot of focus fairly
compelling value proposition certainly
unique
they had a fabulous run they moved away
from this focus throughout their life
but the point is we are looking for
something very similar to this in terms
of an explanation around clarity of
purpose god if you can get past that
first challenge we are very interested
in your company and at that point in
time we're looking to understand the
market strategy what are your unfair
advantages the nuance behind the pay
point I mean you really have first-hand
experience we love listening to
entrepreneurs chat or Steve talking
about the frustration sharing video
after party
they had first-hand experience and many
of the entrepreneurs that we back are
attacking a personal pain we loved back
people that have 10-15 years experience
in a specific industry I recently back
two gentlemen out of the storage
industry one was a key architect in the
early days Network appliance at storage
the other one somebody out of data
domain both fabulous storage companies
and the nuance and depth of their
expertise was wonderful what we're
really looking to garner in the next set
of questions in many ways it's a test is
to understand the depth and substance of
both your passion for the pain
and your ability to orchestrate a
strategy around creating unfair
advantage from a market entry and market
tactics perspective and so you'll
normally get rattled with a number of
and questions standpoint it is your
meeting but just know that we're very
interested in understanding your
detailed expertise in the domain and by
the way I should mention we're rarely
experts I mean venture in general has
very few people that can kind of go
across all the different markets that we
might be investing in and it takes the
time to educate us it's a wonderful
opportunity after you get through that
first challenge around positioning to
grain to gain credibility with the
venture organizations I touched on this
already we invest in both of these areas
existing markets where you might be
looking to create a value proposition
with a 3 or 5 X improvement in price
performance an adjacent market but what
really is most interesting to us is this
opportunity to find new categories we're
often there is no market there's no town
there's no Sam and it's all about those
early beachhead customers we love
knowing that you've gone out and thought
about that and for us I listened to the
prior conversation for those of you that
we're in here there was some discussion
around selling out versus waiting for an
IPO it's certainly our experience that
on the right hand side if it begins to
work it will exceed wildly everyone's
expectations and our own philosophy
around M&A versus an IPO is pretty
simple when it starts to work we
desperately try to convince the
entrepreneurs to remain independent and
that served us very well as a
partnership over 35 years that said if
we're unable to convince them on the
merits of our argument we're not going
to vote against the entrepreneur I think
that's venture specific but it's just
worth noting that we do invest in both
categories but they have very different
market attributes I'm not going to go
into too much detail other than to say
that you know more in his books does a
fabulous job talking about market
tactics for high technology companies
and it encouraged you to be familiar
with how you might create a market entry
strategy that is suitable for startup
talking about channels as an example
something that gives us a great deal of
harper and if you're going after the
enterprise with a high technology
product is real
typically new getting channels to pay
attention to startups at least in our
experience has been very difficult there
are a number of issues with consumer
based companies in a similar light where
it's our belief that you ought to be
able to get meaningful consumer
attraction as a web company without
spending millions of dollars in fact I'd
argue as a function of time over the
last three to five years the cost of
getting a consumer internet service up
and running has begun to approach zero
so as an entrepreneur if I take off my
Sequoia hat you're far better off
getting meaningful consumer feedback and
iterating on that feedback and then
waiting to go and get venture now my
partners would love to have me represent
a different position because we'd like
to be the first dollar in and your first
phone call but but that said there are a
number of markets for the amount of
capital required to get meaningful
consumer feedback is relatively small
this is a personal frustration but if
you look at the competitive
differentiation and the mapping that
happens in the entrepreneurial community
there are so few entrepreneurs that are
truly credible about the existing
incumbents and their advantages versus
their own it is so refreshing to see a
company that's not actually up in the
top right
I mean 98 out of 100 when it comes in
their top right here's why yet it's
really nothing more in many cases than a
wonderful idea in PowerPoint one
fabulous way to build credibility with
the venture community is to really know
your competition intimately to have a
wonderful degree of respect and to
initially position yourself in one
quadrant and over time you might have a
hope or ambition to move up into the top
right but this is a credibility building
exercise you will truly separate
yourself if you have a balanced view of
where you hope to enter the market as a
upstart and over time earn a stronger
market position so some of you might
been wondering what this ball is here
for I kind of told myself that this was
a workshop and if I didn't get any
questions this is like a cold call if
you got the ball
you needed to at least ask a question or
possibly answer one can I pause now and
just ask what are you guys thinking are
there any questions about please see
long shots no question is a bit of a
software business what about the googles
in the Microsoft santiago's of the world
why will they come and eat your lunch as
a as a new entrepreneur sure they can
have 20,000 people developing with your
ugly what what happen is a good answer
that is the lenses what's going to vary
by venture firm but we're very
comfortable investing in and around what
we call an aircraft carrier the
companies you mentioned it's very hard
for them to shift momentum and will
regularly make an investment decision
based on a set of assumptions that the
existing incumbent will not be able to
successfully attack the adjacent market
in fact I actually argue much of our
current portfolio makes that implicit
assumption some firms are going to have
a oversized fear of what these large
incumbents might do but it's certainly
been my experience both being inside one
of these large incumbents and being part
of an upstart it's very rare for a large
company to move on even Google look at
the markets that they're currently
dominating and the ones that they've
attempted to pursue aggressively very
different list
and with this chart can they live up if
you are in a new category as as I
believe my company is then aren't you
more concerned with the axes that I
choose as opposed to the companies that
I put onto that chart and wouldn't I be
choosing those axes with the intent of
putting my company in the upper right or
at least the answer is yes but even day
one as you think about anything more
Cattleya out where you're going to
compete on those two axes but even day
one be credible about at least what the
customer perception is going to be and
rarely as a start-up will you wind up
distancing yourself into the far right
corner certainly over time that will
happen but but normally there's a stage
that we typically call wart removal and
iteration that occurs over 12 18 months
before you can really position yourself
as dominant in an existing market
defensible barriers if you're interested
in the consumer internet or mobile space
this is our biggest concern it's what we
describe as the Malthusian environment
those of you that are philosophy fans
thomas malthus in UK and its theory
around population and eventually its
starving the globe we see this all the
time in certain hot web 2.0 categories
it's also true in a number of mobile
micro landscapes how are we going to
build long-term competitive barriers
we're not comforted by patents I can
tell you that we will often hear the
patent story as a start-up patents
they're interesting I think we should
pursue them aggressively but it's more
of a defensive tactic it doesn't
necessarily need to be technology but
there's great comfort when we hear that
there's a meaningful technical barrier
that's being accomplished through
technology and by the way we're very
comfortable with technical risk we take
that over market risk if you can assure
us that there is a market and you'll be
able to begin to pull together a
world-class team to go up to technology
that's very exciting to us but being
able to explain why there's a meaningful
barrier Ebay had the network effect we
often meet with on to roles that have a
fabulous set of instincts around viral
behavior
intimate understanding of the market
itself or delaying expertise is often a
fabulous varied entry there might be a
set of partnerships that the first mover
is gonna be able to take advantage of or
user-generated content and how that
actually creates stickiness in the
business but the point is at least for
us we are very interested in barriers to
entry if you can get through the first
set of items in the conversation and
unfortunately probably not as interested
in all the raw details around the
technology and if you're an engineer in
the room and I was certainly guilty of
this throughout my career I know I love
talking about technology but as an
investor it's less interesting than
understanding how that technology or
business process or unfair advantage is
going to create a meaningful barrier to
entry please
it's an enormous barrier in our opinion
very few startups get it candidly but
we're seeing more and more than a web
certainly Apple has differentiate
themselves over a couple decades with
simplicity of design but we're big
believers in time we think YouTube
it wasn't like YouTube was the first
site to share video no their first site
to do it in a browser only fashion
through flash so simplicity is
incredibly important and we think often
creates new levels of adoption and first
mover advantages and it's a big leverage
it's not up there and that this was not
meant to represent a comprehensive list
but certainly that's a wonderful way to
go after a market do you know well other
questions on barriers
so here are six slides or business cards
rather that are pretty common for us
when we meet with an early team talked
about humble beginnings but look at the
titles chairman president CEO general
counsel general counsel is always a red
flag when you're looking at a series a
company but in all seriousness this is a
very common problem for us we see these
very stacked groups honey I kind of
wonder outside where are the times 10
programmers where's that wonderful
architect where's the guy with the
fabulous sense of simplicity and market
expertise what we're really looking for
is 3 maybe 4 individuals with very
different expertise lots of dynamic
tension who are times 10 programmers you
know wonderful marketeers
the pedigree is not important certainly
it's kawaii you will find other firms
that take a strategy that they'd like to
have people with an executive history as
part of the founding team it's not part
of our criteria we're happy to back
executives all day long and do quite
often but the point is it's not part of
the way we think about a business and as
you come in we're as interested in who
the doers are and having them join the
meeting as we might be on the future
leader of the company we get tingly when
we meet with a bunch of engineers who
just knocked out some fabulous code for
a mobile effort consumer or effort or a
storage effort who are absolutely world
class now let me not talk a lot in the
meeting but it lends a great deal of
credibility to your efforts just out of
curiosity how many people here have an
engineering background so about half
so touched on this already but
intelligence ambition a clear
understanding of a pain point and in our
case often immigrants but certainly
unknown and underdogs are the people
that we find the most interesting to
back you know the second time third time
entrepreneurs I mean candidly rarely
works and in our own experience we've
done it a handful of times but it hasn't
been nearly as interesting as the first
time they were actually involved with us
now that said we love backing people
they've tried it once or twice before
and weren't wildly successful but
they're still unknown in an underdog so
you guys don't know either one of these
individuals here you knew the first six
pictures I show you but the point is I
think is a good chance two or three
years from now you'll know those faces
fairly unknown today toiling away I have
an Italian partner who immigrated to the
u.s. it was born on the 4th of July in
Italy Doug Leone who is the one that
typically flips to the financials in a
presentation and what he's really doing
is mapping what he perceives to be your
sales mechanism to your business model
and you know probably two times out of
three there are major flaws 50% of the
time
you've lost Doug's confidence in your
ability to build a business because
instinctively you can look at your
numbers and graphs whether you're
plugged in if you will to how to build a
sales marketing and distribution arm for
your business the numbers are incredibly
important and if you don't know to say
you don't know that's ok and that arming
us with a set of financials that's not
believable is more damning than just
leaving them out and this is very common
I think people want to be comforted by
the numbers there's lots of standard
mistakes but the numbers themselves tell
us a lot about the way you're thinking
about the business we have a slight
unfair advantage that we've been around
for 35 years I've seen
lots of piell's both the dream case and
then the reality after we invest and we
have the pleasure of going through what
we call portfolio review as my partner
mark Dempster fully appreciates every
six months where we look at all of our
companies their plan and what happened
and it's a it's a full day it's a
wonderful experience to razz your
partner's on this but rarely do people
hit their numbers that said it's the
disparity and the magnitude of it that
were fixated on so take the time on the
financials and you know I would
encourage you to go look at other
companies and their filings and they go
public on their very first couple of
years we regularly will see plans that
go from zero to product shipping to 25
million to 80 million to two hundred
million dollars that almost never
happens in the history of hi-tech I mean
if you looked at Google in its early
days and read Mike Moritz as description
of the company in our LP letters you'd
think you'd be ready to be shut down so
the point is you can gain a great deal
of credibility by being balanced on the
numbers upfront and certainly a number
of folks in the financial community
specifically venture are going to be
very fixated on your piano if you're
doing something in the SAS area or
consumer internet or mobile or
advertising or even semies there is a
nomenclature around unit economics that
we like to think about when we
contemplate a business model there's a
lot of specialization here I'm not going
to go through all the terms but I assure
you that if you're not on top of how you
might contemplate unit economics for
your business whether it's yields for
semies and how that impacts gross margin
versus MRRR for a SAS business and what
your Radl revenue looks like or cost of
customer acquisition or churn lifetime
value these are all elements that
suggest that you've really got your head
around the economics of your business
this is often more telling than the P&L
and the balance sheet the cash flow
statements for us and
almost every major category has a unique
set of economics that have been laid out
and it's wonderful to have that in black
and white along with ranges so I'm going
to pause here and see if I get any
questions on unit economics get the
football on please
yes with that is the amount of bands and
stores expected each addresses now now
we talk about shipping out dollars with
you every customer and in case YouTube
there was a bandwidth in a storage cost
was measured in fractions of penny but
per user and we're very concerned early
on around monetization but more
concerned about friction and there are
lots of conversations that roll off and
here had with the team around the
balance and we wound up raising more
cash not because we needed it for
headcount because the bandwidth costs
had actually crossed a million dollars a
month
turns out the storage is not a large
issue for you to at least in the early
days because the amount of bits that
were being stored and there's a certain
amount of caching but the bandwidth and
the peering cost were becoming fairly
painful but that was captured even in
the initial series a presentation that a
very good handle for what a 90-second
flash video with a certain quality and
our hope was could we eventually build
an ad monetization scheme that could
produce north of that and that gave us
some comfort we knew what the CPM might
look like and had some knowledge that we
could eventually turn this over with
start to take off we're not big fans of
low margin businesses at Sequoia that's
not to say you can't build wonderful
businesses Flextronics is a great
example Don Valentine is not here but
you know you hear groan in the room
anytime of entrepreneur mentions a gross
margin number below 50% you can build
wonderful businesses in both the low and
high margin area here in the valley I
think you see more healthy gross margins
then you might see in other areas the
globe but you know through our team in
China we're certainly certainly starting
to see wonderful aspects of low margin
businesses
and I think that will continue okay
sales learning curve this is something
that encourage all of you to read this
is a fabulous case that was developed by
Mark Leslie who was the CEO of Veritas
he actually teaches here at the GSB I
think a couple times a year and it's now
an HBS case this is all about the recipe
involved in building revenue and a real
business and there are all these
assumptions that I would characterize
this textbook that go in to what your
revenue ramp looked like how many
salespeople you're going to hire and all
sorts of elements of the business
whether it's positioning sales
compensation training and there's this
view that you can just lay out the
formula and every quarter you're going
to grow 30 or 40 percent just not how it
works there's this enormous challenge in
iteration on the recipe to get to a
meaningful level repeatability in your
business and that's true for an
enterprise business it's true for a
consumer business and the art is to go
slow first focus on the recipe with
world-class people and get to the point
where you have repeatability and it
turns out that if you decide to spend a
great deal of money on talent in your
customer facing organization early on
before you figure out that formula
you're going to burn through your cash
far faster than you should because sales
people are very expensive they're not
going to take the same risk that you're
going to take as an entrepreneur and
until they can actually produce margin
equivalent to two times their
compensation and that's not just the
sales force but it's the SES
you should not have your foot on growth
in your customer facing organization and
so knowing that it might take three four
eight quarters to really figure out what
the formula is is incredibly important
Cisco as it stands today went for seven
quarters up down up down very small
sales force unclear whether it would be
a meaningful business but they focused
on the recipe and there was a incredibly
important early sales executive there
and what the patience of the team they
eventually built an enormous business
but it took six seven quarters for them
to figure out the recipe take your time
make sure your business plan reflects
that when we see a set of financials
whether it's in consumer mobile or
enterprise space that suggests that
you're going to go from nothing at
product introduction to some enormous
number around the monotonically
increasing basis over four or five
quarters you lose credibility this is a
wonderful case and I really want to
continue to iterate that you should pick
it up and read it there's not a book yet
but there ought to be touched on this
already the financials in your plan say
a whole lot and it's certainly not a
time to be glib overly aggressive that
would encourage you guys to hold off on
financials even in the first meeting if
you're not confident about the numbers
one of the wonderful things about the
internet and mobile space is you really
can experiment and have a pretty good
handle on what the cost of customer
acquisition might look like on what
churn looks like with just a little bit
of money or bootstrapping yourself we've
got a number of folks in the portfolio
that started their business on their
credit cards in their apartment and they
got a hefty valuation in the series a
because they are able to come in and
show even at a micro level early
consumer adoption and an early sense of
what the unit academics might look like
on a validated basis small sample but
still very compelling to us
is it pesetas grulla time is it it can
be as small as a hundred if it's a
controlled beta and we're looking at
that point in time for repeatability and
you know how often and the loyalty bases
are coming back we've seen scenarios
where it was as small as you know a
dozen but but in reality somewhere
between 100 and maybe a hundred thousand
if you can create some notion that
there's real credibility and
independence behind the numbers that's
very valuable to us you've taken out one
of the biggest issues and that's
consumer adoption risk you probably
begun to show your ability to iterate
because my guess is you bring it up and
you iterate and a lot of these young
teams will change the site or the
offering every other day or every day
and that gives us a chance to watch
what's happening with the site over time
and it this is in many ways I'm talking
about startups and iterative intensively
so business and if that's in the DNA
fabulous we've had the good fortune of
being in business with a number of
people out of PayPal and I think the one
thing that sets the PayPal alumni
organization apart from many others is
their ability to iterate and you know it
turns out that Steve and Chad
they were junior guys at PayPal junior
junior you know max is off with slide
but I mean these were relatively young
junior people in the organization but in
their DNA from PayPal was an ability to
iterate in a very intense way with very
short time periods with thoughtful open
honest feedback about the marketplace I
think there was also an ability at
PayPal excuse my language to not you
know [ __ ] themselves they were very
honest with one another about the
consumer feedback what was working what
was and it really has set that culture
apart and I think we'll continue to see
wonderful startups being led by people
who were part of that DNA if you're
thinking about starting a company go get
somebody that's spent a couple years in
an organization as you think about
blending your own team and the DNA of
your organization
God where do I start here when I was
trucking up and down Sand Hill Road my
co-founder I really had no clue about VC
meetings and what they were expecting
and bizarre behavior lots of questions
at times I didn't quite understand
mystery on how to actually get the
meeting there was all these you know
tribal tales on how to get a meeting
with kleiner or Squire MDV or whatnot
let me just start with when are you
ready boy wouldn't want to show the
venture community my slide deck the
first time I'm actually going through it
you really need to be heated up with
some people that you would consider
advisors I also think it's important to
think about who you want to have in that
meeting single individuals fine but if
you've built the beginnings of a
wonderful team may be unknown maybe
underdogs bring them in find a way to
have them participate I laid out what I
think are the five most important
aspects to kind of convey but it's your
meeting
my partner's can do rail a freight train
but it's wonderful to see an
entrepreneur take ownership take the mic
and own that meeting and listen to the
questions if they're already going to be
answered later than the deck point that
out and move on it's it's a wonderful
opportunity to be creative but it's also
incredibly important that you own that
meeting and manage it many groups might
be off looking at your blackberry or not
paying attention I'm not sure that's a
group of people you want to be working
with to be candid I mean it's an hour
it's a wonderful opportunity it's
certainly been the most rewarding part
of my career being an entrepreneur and
spending time in those early days
iterating on the plan and eventually
going out and getting funding but it's a
great honor for us in the venture
community to sit on the other side of
the table and listen to all of you and
you guys should feel that you have
ownership and manage that meeting now
some might ask you what else you're
talking to wouldn't tell I ain't
scarcity and a certain amount of
openness is a
proprietary Asst you're in an
environment here in Silicon Valley where
there are probably a couple of hundred
venture firms and you do have choices
and I would encourage you to go out and
seek out the right partner but also be
aware of what market terms and market
prices look like if they don't get back
to you after the first meeting and say
they're going to after a week I'd send
maybe one email I wouldn't take it
personally they're all pretty busy but
there are a lot of people in the venture
community that do not follow up and let
them know that they're going to not be
interested and it can be very
frustrating as an entrepreneur
yeah I've been funded but I've also been
passed on numerous times the debate
itself that might ensue when somebody
tells you why they're going to pass on
the investment opportunity is something
that I would encourage you to pause on
as an entrepreneur and really listen
because it's an opportunity to hone your
presentation and your thoughts around
the business for the next meeting
please let's do this friend you get them
through their party meeting
females on call and all contingent event
that because you're going under for an R
and and you want them to remember their
be there when they show up for an R so
how do you warm them up yeah I guess I
have a slightly different view I'm
speaking as a entrepreneur now rather
than Sequoia because I may ask you for
your PowerPoint slides if you send
something but I actually think you want
to attempt to create interest with a
very brief paragraph no longer
representation of the unique value
proposition and the unfair advantage
that's it they ask for the slides I
wouldn't send it first of all you can't
get them to pay attention without slides
let alone handing them to you know
they're going to move to the back of the
presentation it's an opportunity for you
to manage the meeting I also think that
there are lots of reasons not to have
your slide deck especially in this
Malthusian environment center around the
venture community and so yes there are
things you might want to do to warm them
up I think it's appropriate to spend a
few minutes talking about your
backgrounds but if you can get to that
clarity of purpose that compelling
unique value proposition in the first
five or ten minutes you've got their
interests in fact I just tell you right
now some of the best presentations I've
been in they have gotten through all the
core elements I just touched on in less
than 15 minutes now we don't want to
leave in 15 normally what we try to do
at that point in time is bring the rest
of the partnership down and somehow try
to find a way to be in business with
that group of entrepreneurs that day we
can go from meeting to term sheet to
money in the bank in less than 24 hours
and the point is if you would actually
do your homework in advance create some
scarcity value work out what you think
are going to be the key questions in
advance and really think through how you
want to respond you're in a wonderful
you're going to get lots of people that
say well you won't take a meeting let's
look at the PowerPoint well are those
the kind of guys that you want to be in
business with I mean in many ways that
venture community works for you
I'm not sure entrepreneurs understand
that day one but after a couple years of
having Pierre with his boot on my neck
on my board I realize no Pierre is
really there as an asset to me as an
entrepreneur and I finally figured out
how to leverage Pierre but the point is
you want to be in business with people
that you feel good about and I would
encourage you to be thoughtful on who
you target in that group of 300 but not
share certainly not in this environment
especially with the iteration that goes
on on the web and in the mobile space
competition if you have a term sheet and
it's got a short fuse you're going to
get a reason attention now there are
people that have used that and represent
that they have term sheets and flat out
don't we don't like being treated as a
stalking horse either and so there's a
delicate balance but if there is
meaningful interest whether it's rain
jewels or the venture community I think
certainly you're going to garner a
different pace from the venture
community you know we we think about the
business in lots of different ways but
if we hear from non trinova that we have
a meeting ten days from now but they
recently received the term sheet more
than likely we'll drop almost everything
that day or the next day cancel some
meetings and find a way to get together
I mean it's our business to try to get
in front of folks like yourself and if
that is an ephemeral situation and
something we were absolutely going to
jump on I think you'll find that to be
the case with most venture firms you
will find people kind of hiding behind
their rationality they don't want to
have the debate and that's a little bit
unfortunate I mean if you're open minded
as an entrepreneur and want to
understand the rationale behind that
partnerships decision and really listen
and don't push back so much it can be a
wonderful opportunity to learn a lot of
firms and individuals have been burnt
and wind up candidly pissing off the
entrepreneur cuz they are passionate
zealots and they don't want to be told
that their baby is ugly and that it
becomes a bit of a challenge and you'll
find them
pay if you ask and point out that you're
not going to debate but you really would
like to learn from I think almost
everybody in the venture community to be
happy to share their thoughts and by the
way we're often wrong I'm embarrassed to
tell you the list of great firms that we
passed on but they include companies
like Salesforce and checkpoint software
the firewall company and many others so
that should not discourage you as an
entrepreneur I mean you will get lots of
interest in no doubt even in those cases
they're going to have lots of people
that decide they want to pass other
questions
Stockton the UNC structure that
paragraph say the email to ideally
that's the hook right immediately I
realize boy there's a compelling and
unique value proposition and clarity of
purpose and so the the big hurdle that
we often go into a meeting on wondering
whether there might be an opportunity
has already addressed in the initial
email definitely not much more than that
but I it's a wonderful way to create
interest in the venture community you
know by the way this whole mystery of
how to get a meeting
it varies firm by firm but certainly it
Sequoia our emails are on the website
we're in the business with meeting folks
like you and we're here to invest not
pass so reach out there's no need to
find somebody that's somehow associated
with you know somebody else at the
partnership and I think that's true
almost across the board today in the
venture community wasn't the case 20
years ago but certainly is now slides
just no certainly
I know the Sequoias webpage actually
suggests sent slides I think took ideas
at my Beck Sequoia Capital now we're
here now because without your VC hat on
how can how can an entrepreneur say I
want to be in touch with you avoid that
process when that means what we feel
like what we know there's no an ace here
there's sending slides up Wiley what's
the risk well look I will normally ask
for slides and look they never leave the
partnership in our case and I think
that's true for a lot of firms but I'll
ask because I want to qualify who else
should I have in the meeting should I
have you know mark Dempster's I have
Greg McAdoo show you have Mike Morris I
am trying to figure out how to make that
a productive first meeting and often the
slide deck will allow me to gain more
information about that even in our own
partnership I will not forward to the
partners that I am asking to come to the
meeting the slide deck why because they
listen to six or seven presentations a
day I want them to pay attention we all
have a DD and so as an entrepreneur I've
been in those meetings where people are
on their Blackberry or what that's very
frustrating you've been passionate
you've spent all this time working on
the material and so I have empathy for
you but that said I'm giving you my
advice as an entrepreneur I wouldn't
send the PowerPoint I'd certainly be
willing to follow up with it after you
present because it's likely to go from
three or four people potentially the
whole partnership well they're likely to
have a conversation between your initial
meeting and your next meeting about the
opportunity and at some point in time
you want to be transparent and
forthcoming I think that's part of the
relationship building that will occur
from the first meeting on but I think to
get a first meeting it isn't necessary
to send PowerPoint
PowerPoint slides from an
entrepreneurial perspective I think I
was pretty slow to figure this out a
slide presentation that presents very
well doesn't necessarily read very well
yeah and vice versa
and so as much as it's painful to the
VCS to see these things over and over
again it's very painful for us to create
them I never wanted to create two of
them so I don't send it around quickly
are incredibly important but I'm glad
you brought it up because there are
firms and I don't think this is true at
Sequoia but there are firms that will
use the PowerPoint presentation in the
email to be initial secondary filter
process and it turns out to look at the
PowerPoint they'll make a quick
assumption based on the PowerPoint
itself without having the benefit of
hearing from you that passionate
entrepreneur and that energy that goes
into what you're trying to do and
they'll decide not to take the meeting
you may not hear about that for three or
four days but they'll come up with some
BS excuse on you know double-booked
Deana and trust me they're passing and
they're passing because they looked at
the PowerPoint and it's just not
compelling enough and so I think you
want to create the opportunity to be
there and deliver the message face to
face firsthand and then what Nicole
be actually useful to take about the
real facts we're talking to and other
subjects at my campus would be very
honest with pcs like if you're not sure
about financials so which point do you
sort of have to lay the cards of the
table to establish well it's no
different than any other human
interaction I think trust and honesty
and integrity there's real substance
that will come out of those
conversations and I think being
transparent and honest is a far better
strategy than you know being glib or
overstating and potentially even
misrepresenting that said there are a
number of items that as an entrepreneur
are not in your interest to share with
the venture community what other venture
firms are you talking to you know what
was the valuation the term sheet that
you received these are things that
candidly to create a market dynamic you
are far better off holding those cards
close to your chest until you decide who
you want to work with once it was
approached in tech investing where you
see like the big opportunity suppose to
be born Paulson what's the difference is
for this process because I mean a lot of
times for example because you said I
mean don't worry too much about market
size for example and I feel like
especially for clean tech firms market
size is probably a bigger issue than the
start
so we talk about energy because we think
there are not only green or clean
opportunities but lots of interesting
opportunities in gas and fuel and what
we'd call dirty tech but we are very
active in the space a number of the
elements that I touched on earlier are
still true in fact in the last year we
have probably backed five well call
energy opportunities out of a total of a
15 investments it's almost a third of
what we've done in the last year has
been in the energy sector market size
ultimately look it's not a negative to
suggest that over time this might become
a big market but we're fixated on the
initial focus and the unfair advantage
which is very hard to do in a broad
market with the existing incumbents you
know if that was the case that many of
the incumbents would extend their
product line and just move into the area
there are a set of elements that come
together with a start-up that and then
create wonderful opportunities for all
of you and a spectacular investment
landscape for us and those are the
things that were interested in I am sure
there are lots of energy opportunities
out there that are interesting companies
and businesses that will be profitable
and create a nice return for the prior
ship as an example installing solar
panels I mean it's a big opportunity
right there probably across North
America I am Not sure that all by itself
being a professional services business
is going to get us leaning way forward
if there's some creative process around
it we might I don't know if I answered
your question or not but large market
all by itself is not a damning data
point for Sequoia the point is you know
a lot of people listen to venture and
they think to focus on size and market
and if they can't claim that they've got
a billion dollar market day one we're
not interested and they're worried about
being pigeon-holed as a feature oh no
looks for six businesses that I brought
up on humble beginnings we're all
features day one little tiny businesses
my question is besides of money
what does Sequoia add and would Yahoo
will and YouTube these companies without
Sequoia
III think it's very dangerous for us to
suggest for a moment that we added
anything to any of those opportunities I
think there's a philosophy at Sequoia
that we're all about sitting behind the
entrepreneurs and not getting in front
of press we describe it as prey jumping
if you will when there's a wonderful
outcome for company and the next thing
you know you listen to the investors
being quoted in the Wall Street Journal
so so it's important to us that we
properly represent our position we were
certainly investors we think we were
additive to the process and I'd
encourage you to go ask them as
entrepreneurs that said the key
ingredient in our success has been
identifying and intersecting with
wonderful unknown underdogs over the
course the last 35 years philosophically
we have benefited from a culture that
really started with Don Valentine who
has always focused on going long when
things are going well and not selling
out and I think culturally that has
transcended a couple of generations
within Sequoia and at least in those
cases you have a couple of independent
companies they're still even Yahoo one
that wind up selling out you two in
those conversations with Steve and Chad
there was a lot of dialogue around
remaining independent a billion six at
the talent time sounded like an enormous
amount of money I think if you look at
the traffic and the business that
represents to Google today and thought
about that as a standalone company you
might argue that it's worth 10 15 20
billion dollars today that said we
absolutely supported our entrepreneurs
Steven chat in that decision I think was
the right decision for the two of them
and has turned out to be a wonderful
business and I think Google has been
incredibly additive but we would never
take anything away from our
entrepreneurs and there's a lot of pride
within Sequoia I'm not being upfront
with the press or
the credit if you will I'm called a
person energy cycle first of all how
many like traditional anything's are you
seeing that habitable traditional energy
sources that kind of stuff and secondly
love it when you receive a business plan
related to energy and you see that the
management team has maybe 80% of the
solution figured out but then you know
of another team someone else would send
you something and they had maybe in
every major 20% figure out we ever serve
as a connection between with you and we
answer the second question first so I
think in terms of trying to act as an
intermediary absolutely an often attempt
to do that I think are batting ratio is
you know on the order of you know to 300
it's not a spectacular track record in
that area in terms of trying to get
teams connected the certain amount of
passion and DNA building has to get
created in a start-up independently and
we don't want to ever force two groups
together that's often met with disaster
in terms of the number of traditional
energy or what I would characterize it's
dirt eat a copper tuna tease that we've
intersected with you were probably
meeting with three or four a week on
that order there's probably twice that
number that would characterize as green
but there is a lot of activity in energy
right now it's one of those hot sectors
are aureus is a bit Malthusian already
and unlike the internet mobile space the
capital intensity this sector is a lot
closer to what we characterize in our
semi or systems business so we are being
cautious extremely so when it comes to
making energy investments although I
have to tell you a mark I appreciate
this
we just recently signed the term sheet
with a couple guys who spent their
careers at GE and large power companies
that are in their late 60's and although
I painted this picture of very young
entrepreneurs early on we're delighted
to be in business those guys and the
expertise that comes out of GE in a
number of fields is just staggering and
there are certainly opportunity
there was another question or somewhere
of running a business we can get new
meaningful data back into Xero
meaningful meaningful data you know back
from I guess what the users are
I guess it's cheaper to run business
these days and some internet with that
mind like how do you know when the right
time is to get money if it is the case
that you get get some work it's a little
well it may not be money that drives you
that decision I think if you can create
a disruption where you have a meaningful
increase in the potential value of the
company and you dearest a major
component of your plan you know
anecdotal I'll be a meaningful consumer
about some notion of what loyalty
numbers might look like if we scale that
up breaking through a major technology
risk anything that can create a
disruption in the risk profile of your
company depending on where that lies
it's worth thinking about doing that on
your own MasterCard on your own nickel I
was funded by Sequoia in 1996 Monte
Kirsten and I put up our own money took
no salary pulled together roughly half a
million dollars and got our first
product with six fabulous engineers out
the door and got to initial market
option before we whatever went and saw
anybody in the venture community and it
was a very different dynamic than going
to PowerPoint we had a product in the
marketplace we had meaningful adoption
at that time we had a downloadable
product in the early days of the
internet and it meaningfully changed the
economic equation around the ownership
of the company so we even if exit had
seventy four seventy five percent of the
company within the employee base and so
as you think about ownership and
economic value to not only your
co-founders but to the team itself if
you can D risk the company in a very
thoughtful scrappy way encourage you to
do it not to mention for us on the other
side of the table it shows Hudspeth and
stones that you're willing to take that
risk maybe this is the substance of what
we're
for when we're talking about underdogs
and passion we love hearing about
somebody taking that risk and we are
absolutely willing to pay a higher
valuation when we see real progress
along that dimension that encourage you
to do that now you know if I put my
sequoia hat on boy please the moment you
have the idea come on down we really do
want to be the first phone call but you
know in reality we're happy to be a part
of it it's a really tough question I
think there's a wonderful group of
angels out there and it turns out that
you think the Angels can be additive to
the creation of the business and provide
a perspective that would be valuable to
the business creation encourage you to
go pursue that path that the challenge
is is you build that capital structure
rarely does the angel community want to
continue to invest in the series B and
the Serie C and the service D and if you
take a meaningful chunk of your initial
capitalization table the cap table with
a company structure and allocate it to
angels you create a somewhat fragmented
foundation the venture community is
basically expected to continue to
support the company assuming certain
milestones that are being met well it's
you know five or ten million dollar
valuation twenty fifty two hundred five
hundred and new investors will expect to
see existing investors show them the
money and that's probably the only major
risk and taking a little bit of angel
money if it's too much it can become a
problem you need to be candid for us the
angel community at Sequoia is a
wonderful partner but at times they're
our biggest competition you know we make
on a thousand dollar investments a lot
of people don't think about Sequoia as
somebody that's willing to do a seed but
you know we're happy to be part of an
early stage seed investment some of the
very best returns the Sequoia came from
incredibly small early investments but
it's a wonderful group be picky think
about who your partners are
here's to know you spoke a little bit
about IP as an offensive strategy
he said there's also signs of skepticism
in that would you do something custom a
patent against exactly how broad a
patent that is how much that really
protects what kind of consideration for
you is that somebody if they have a
technology that they made of this method
this product happening as a play in any
decision airing I think having a
patentable technology and having patents
is a wonderful way to think about the
intellectual property in the business
and a potential technical barrier but
it's probably more important to us that
it's difficult to repeat it difficult to
build then the notion that we're going
to defend our market position not an
iteration and and you know quickness of
feet but by hiring some lawyers and
using our patent to make sure that
anybody that comes in competes gets
spanked that's a very expensive
proposition I don't have any attorneys
in the group but you are okay be careful
what I say but but it's a very it's a
very expensive proposition for a
start-up to hire a legal team in it I've
been on the other side of that a handful
of times and there's some wonderful
people at Wilson Sonsini I'd been in the
business with on the litigation front
and three guys out of MIT all PhD
Central Casting in the video space
fabulous patents the guys behind MPEG
and HGTV and we wound up pursuing a
defensive set of tactics around their
patents and quickly burned through ten
million dollars of the company's money
and that happened in 15 months and so
what absolutely worried about whether we
might be stepping on somebody else's
intellectual property and that is a
concern that is something that we will
investigate in certain areas consumer
internet we you know are less concerned
but there are sectors in mobile or in
systems technology where we do think
there's defensible patents that we might
be violating memory is an example and
flash is a landmine when it comes to
patents and so we are sensitive by
sector on the offensive nature of other
companies we as an example Feherty I we
don't want to be on your side of TI's
legal team trying to defend a patent
situation and we'll do almost anything
we can to work with the management team
to avoid litigation and attorneys on
that dimension we think attorneys are
wonderful for lots of aspects of
building a business not necessarily
patent litigation other questions that
the risk is a huge hit Rahzel well I
told you earlier man it turns out that
there are times in our opinion that it
makes sense to consider an acquisition
and we'll even encourage not to in order
to do that but when it's working our
disposition and culture is to go along
because it's going to continue to
surprise you to the upside I mean if you
sat around the table at Sequoia and
heard the history of some of these early
companies and even just read our LEP
reports but what are today large fortune
100 companies you'd understand that
comment but we will never vote against
our entrepreneurs as a firm I think it
varies and you heard it in the earlier
discussion today it varies by firm
philosophically we believe that we're in
the business of producing extraordinary
returns for our LPS and our batting
averages you know around 500s about half
the companies we invest in the early
stage business don't work out and it's
very humbling aspect of venture the ones
that do we're hoping that maybe one out
of a group of 40 investments in the
portfolio produces what we would
consider a black swan or an
extraordinary return and it's our goal
to try to be involved with the
entrepreneur and the concept that might
just create that kind of return every
year and they will rarely happen if
you're not willing to go along but there
are all sorts issues between the venture
community and the investors and the
entrepreneur that are challenging at
times including how entrepreneurs
amongst themselves and their co-founders
might be dealing with the same question
some wanting liquidity others wanting to
go along I actually think that's a more
difficult question the venture community
is at least dealt with it many times
when you have co-founders that have
different views it's often the very
first time in their lives that they've
got an opportunity to get financially
independent it's a difficult question
it's one that speaks to getting
comfortable with the human traits of
your investors
please have you find it the only speech
I designed to operate in several drop in
solo conscious and it's so balanced well
I think there is wonderful on perrault
Alan come across the globe we came to
conclusion four five years ago that some
of the most important tech companies
will not be started in Silicon Valley in
the next couple decades and that they'll
be started in other parts Eastern Europe
China India so forth not a big fan of
having a early stage company try to
target multiple geographies day one
open-minded about R&D or certain
elements of business being in multiple
locations but you know the ideal
scenario is a very tight-knit small
elite team of times ten producers
working on you know with passion and
initial product offering because the
iteration itself really requires
spectacular communication but there's
all sorts of examples now if you told us
that your assistance company and you
wanted to open up Europe and Asia
simultaneous with North America we tell
you you're crazy it just makes no sense
it gets back to the sales are incurred
from mark Leslie where you really need
to focus on your messaging and you're
far better off figuring out what's going
to work in Europe or North America than
trying to tackle all three in the
consumer internet space is very
different you know you open you up you'd
be surprised you know Australia and Asia
you we're always stunned as to where the
initial traffic comes from in our
early-stage companies in the consumer
internet space mobile is dominated by
geographies outside of North America
well much of the innovation is happening
outside the United States two more
questions trouble oh no you please aside
to hang a screen for entrepreneurs
want to go long specifically I know on
your website you mentioned you look for
immigrants who look for people that have
taken risks or ibly what are the
specific either questions you ask for
screens you have to know that someone's
going to want to take it long and
supposed to sell out earlier I think the
the passion and the ambition around the
concept itself and knowing that they
have a desire to see something through
to their vision I think it's very hard
to predict how they'll behave when
they're faced with the opportunity and
you and I both know an entrepreneur that
was actually picture earlier who has
already faced a couple of challenging
questions around should he sell out
should he go along but it's just hard to
predict and it's kind of an
in-the-moment situation I'd like to
think that we can screen for it but at
least to date I don't think we've been
very successful okay I want to flipped I
think to just one last comment
I think we covered most of this I would
just leave you with a personal anecdote
about entrepreneurship all of you in
this room are in a wonderful environment
and I'd like to think our underdogs and
individuals that have come cotton on to
a unique compelling value proposition
and encourage you to take the plunge
have some courage even if it's not
financially rewarding I think you'll
find it one of the most emotional
rewarding experiences in your entire
life if not your career in deference to
my wife and kids